so we just talked about
the flight path the trajectory right the
uh the process tolerate accept celebrate
participate
okay like burn let's burn that into our
our minds
that's the way it always goes tolerate
accept
celebrate participate so here it is
again okay from the post-millennial it
says in response to a texas state
representative announcing that he will
file legislation to ban drag shows from
having children in their audience
california state senator scott weiner
proposed offering drag queen curriculum
in schools
responding to a tweet from
representative brian slayton of texas in
which he announced the legislation
weiner wrote
and it's just
i mean the fact that his name is weiner
is it's just
so perfect he said this guy just gave me
a bill idea offering drag queen 101 as
part of the k-12 curriculum
attending drag queen story time will
satisfy the requirements
okay now
you might think
that you see the tweet there you might
think this is slightly tongue-in-cheek
and even if it is it's still
uh
horrifying and disgusting and this guy's
a groomer scumbag
but oh no this is not a joke
this is not a joke from this guy he he
will introduce that legislation
and we'll have more examples of other
legislation that he's introduced before
just uh just to show you that you know
he could put his money where his mouth
is in fact we'll continue it says in
2020 weiner author authored a bill
that would end discrimination against
lgbt people quote unquote by providing
exemptions from the sex offender
registry the bill sb 145 made exemptions
for people who are convicted of certain
offenses as long as a person convicted
is no more than 10 years older than the
minor with the minor being no younger
than 14.
this bill would exempt from mandatory
registration under the act a person
convicted of certain offenses involving
minors if the person is not more than 10
years older than the minor and if that
offense is the only one requiring person
the person to register
um
and
there were some other ones as well more
recently weiner author authored a bill
that would authorize the creation of
safe consumption sites within cities and
counties
um so that's another one who's the bill
where people can go and use drugs
also weiner alongside fellow state
senator todd gloria authored a bill that
passed back in 2017 that removes federal
penalties and prison time
for people that knowingly expose a
sexual partner to hiv
so prior to
the uh weiner coming along he was um
unfortunate phrasing there
prior to this guy it was it was
illegal in the state of california as it
still is i think at least in some states
in the country it should be in every
state to knowingly infect somebody with
hiv as in if you have sex with somebody
and you're hiv positive you have a legal
responsibility to tell them ahead of
time of course that should be the law
um
but now
thanks to weiner you can
intentionally and knowingly infect
somebody with hiv and it's not a crime
so that's where that's where this guy's
coming from and that's why when he says
that he's gonna make a bill
requiring mandatory drag queen classes
for children oh he'll do it
and i repeat what i said yesterday that
um
[Music]
i very much welcome democrats making
this
their new
cause
okay i don't i don't welcome
these kinds of classes
in public school
of course
though honestly i mean if you're in
california
living in california number one and
number two you're in california you have
your kids in public school in california
then uh
i mean what do what do you expect like
that just
that's that's almost inexcusable
at this point
but what i what i welcome and what i
want
is for the democrats to explicitly come
out
just to say what they already think what
we know they think which is that this is
a good thing and uh to circle the wagons
around it so that everybody else can see
another another great mask off moment
for the left
so that all the normal people out there
however many still exist can see this
and like you can decide do you really
is this is this what you want is this
what you believe in
you want to vote for people support
people who think that we should mix drag
queens and kids
another part of the process
aside from tolerate except celebrate
participate
the other thing that you find is um
there's this kind of stages of denial or
how denial kind of morphs into defense
so
um that's the other thing we always see
with the left
so first when it came to this you know
drag queens and kids originally they
said
that's not really happening that's a
it's a it's not it's not happening
that's that's not really a thing this is
all yeah it's a it's a right-wing
conspiracy theory
uh there might be a few examples of it
but it that's that's very very rare and
it's a you know it's not a big deal it's
not really happening
and then
how quickly we go from that to
oh it is happening but it's good
it's not happening
okay it is happening but it's good
and then that goes to
it is happening it's good
oh and it's mandatory
so we go from not happening to mandatory
and that thing and that can um that
progress process can play out very
quickly
that can happen within the span of like
hours okay
and i think we're gonna see that here
because um
the left has been ramping up as we've
been covering on this show libs of tick
tock on twitter has been um doing a lot
of work to reveal this this is a an
increasing trend now on the left
of uh drag queens and kids and the worst
iteration of that
the most evil form of course is
when the kid is actually enlisted to be
the drag queen so here's something that
tick tock had
um
this is i i still don't know where i'm
not sure if we know where this happened
but some kind of bar
we have adults
cheering on
uh for a child drag queen
let's
see this for just a moment
let me tell you one of the fiercest
performers yet
you guys haven't seen nothing yet please
give it up for the one the only kingdom
queen
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so you can see that that is an
actual child that we're talking about
[Music]
i can't even watch this all right who
could turn it off
i mean that's the kind of thing you have
to see it
because if you don't see it then you
won't believe it
i think there's still a lot of people if
you told them that this is happening
that child
drag queens
are dancing for
for adults at gay clubs
you told that to say it's an average
person on the street they're gonna say
that's not they're not gonna believe you
they're not gonna believe it's happening
and that's why the work that you know
accounts like lives of ticktock are
doing that's why it's important to see
this is actually happening this is a
real thing
okay and it's not just a couple of ins
instant incidents it's it's happening
all over the place
this is
basically this is you know this is this
is baka bazi okay which is which is uh
afghanistan and a lot of our veterans
who spent time in afghanistan
unfortunately
um confronted this and and were very
made very much aware of this uh of this
tradition in the culture among among the
men in afghanistan
baccabazi or quote-unquote dancing boys
and that's where
um men in afghanistan will sit around
and they'll watch
uh little boys dressed up as girls
dancing for them and then of course
there's a lot of sexual abuse and child
rape that happens as well um which by
the way is is
you know kind of redundant to even say
that because the event itself is child
sexual abuse already
and
you hear about that in afghanistan i
remember hearing about that for the
first time
when we first went into afghanistan
and in this country people were
horrified
and you had veterans coming home from
afghanistan traumatized
by having witnessed it especially
witnessed it and they're not allowed to
do anything about it they're being
instructed by their higher-ups that uh
they can't stop it
coming home traumatized because of that
and then uh what do you know
15 years later same damn thing is
happening here
and it's being defended
in the mainstream
by leftists and democrats
and let them defend it
defend it defend it loudly loud and
proud come on you just come out come out
and and give us give us your argument
by the way this is the same thing
remember i said that when they propose
something it's up to them to explain it
and defend it
okay you have to force them to do it
because they're playing the same game
with this by the way
there was um
i've seen a lot of this on twitter and
one example is a charlotte climber
i think works for
one of these a human rights campaign or
one of these radical trans lgbt
organizations militant
and uh posing the question of well i
i really don't i'm not sure i don't
understand why it's so wrong to mix
children and drag queens could someone
explain to me why it's wrong
so we've heard that a lot from the left
people with platforms prominent people
saying oh i'm open to
understanding why you guys object to it
but why don't you explain it
okay we shouldn't need to explain it and
we don't have to explain it that should
be if it's not immediately obvious to
you why it's wrong then that says
something very troubling about you but
also let me flip that around around
um you are the one
proposing this you're the one it's your
side introducing this into the culture
you explain why we need to do it okay
you you give us the defense of it
what's good about it
why do kids need this
kids are getting we're getting along
just fine they're they're just being
kids they're playing they're using their
imaginations they're living you know
innocent child-like lives as they should
you're coming along and saying oh you
know you know what they need they need
drag
so that's up to you to defend and
explain
which you can't do
um so far
or at least the defense is not anything
that you'll say about
because the real reason that you want to
do it is because that you have an actual
agenda to sexualize children you don't
want to say that out loud yet
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content